welcome to my talk
i'm ming chen hong
i'm the co-founder and ceo of blue sky
data we are a very new venture
focused on building the future
of
data infra on the cloud
and before that
i worked on data and ml infra both in
big companies and small startups
and i'm passionate in building products
that are not just technically exciting
but
truly useful to our users and impactful
to their business
i also love
supporting
i also love startups and founders and
have had the privilege of supporting
some of them
over the last few years
data warehouses are starting to move to
the cloud
yes
i do have the clicker sorry
let me see
yeah okay
okay so this is the slider thank you
thank you shinji
data warehouses are starting to move to
the cloud
the market size of data warehouses
and data clouds are estimated by garner
and others to be in the range of 40 to
50 billion dollars
and yet we see the current market
leaders
the snowflakes and data breaks
having an annual revenue of around 1
billion to 2 billion range
which means
the movement of data warehouses to the
cloud
is only just beginning
and we've got so much work to do
so
if you are looking for the next big
thing in the next five to ten years
we think this could be a life changing
opportunity
now before we get too excited about the
future
i thought it would be useful to look at
the history a bit
back in the 1970s
that's before many of us were born
including myself
we see
oracles and others starting
the first generation of relational
database products and they targeted
oltp or transactional workloads
and then we also see academic products
and open source projects like
ingress and postgres
and followed by in the 90s
specifically purpose built analytical
products like
mdx and olap engines
then in the mid 2000s there's a new
generation of column stores that are
significantly increasing the scalability
and the speed for analyzing a huge
amount of data
but just within a short amount number of
years we have the open source based
products like hadoop and hive
revolutionizing how data is being stored
and managed
and yet they also left a lot of promise
unfulfilled
and that gave rise to the modern data
house data clouds and the open data
lakes
as we can see
the wheels of innovation keep spinning
and even if we might like the current
generation of data cloud
we think they're just one more stop
in the evolutionary journey
there's never been a greater time
for us to innovate
and make a fundamental
impact
on how
the future data can be managed on the
cloud
i will tell you more about my thoughts
of the future but let me start with
sharing with you some personal career
stories
i spent four years
at a company called retica that helped
me transition from being a database
researcher to an engineer
and i learned so much in this journey
before the journey i thought technology
is the only thing that matters
to build a successful
enterprise database company
and after the journey
i got to understand there's so much more
to tell you an example
advertica
we managed to build an auto tuner
it's called database designer
and this is in order to compete
effectively with the incumbents like
oracles and teradatas
they all have built a large army of dbas
that know how to tune the user's
workflow workloads in order to optimize
for their performance and cost
now
vertica
is a new kind of engine
just like an f1 sports engine that's
game changing it could be 10 times
faster
but the problem is
without proper tuning
all the potentials get squandered
unfortunately
only employees at relica
know how to tune the engine
nobody in the market out there knew how
to how to tune this so as a result the
company sees it as
a strategic priority
to build out such an auto tuner so that
our customers
and our sales engineers can go and push
a button
and
the product will automatically analyze
users workloads and figure out how to
lay out the data how to partition and
sort and encode
the tables
to bring out the best performance
and the cost
and this was a game changer
not only because it is technically
challenging but more importantly this
addressed a key pain point in our users
and in our own sales workflow so as a
technologist
i think to maximize our own impact
we will need to focus on
what is the key pain point of our
customers
and that will also maximize our products
commercial success
and that is a key lesson i would like to
share
and by the way
for some other parts of my career this
has also happened
but i'm happy to report that i
think i recovered and
benefited a lot from the learnings but
maybe let's talk about that some other
day
now let's get back to talking about the
future of data infra
what do we see as the current set of
challenges and the opportunities
we think that to talk about them
it's good to first look at
the problem from the lens of these three
important personas
first we have the data engineers
and we see they are increasingly
struggling with dealing with the
increased infra complexity
resulting from their own diversity of
the data workloads
i was just talking to a data engineering
team this morning from their airlines
and they were telling me they're using a
combination of three data warehouses
and this is not uncommon
teams like them
would love to offload the intro
complexity so they can focus more on
contributing to their own product
features and contribute to the business
top line
and second we have our query users
they are writing a lot of queries
but
they are really sick of waiting
waiting for the queries to come back
and waiting for their infra colleagues
to optimize for their queries
they can be a lot more empowered
and productive
if
we have the right tools for them
where they are to help them
write better and faster queries
and last but not least we have the cios
and the management
that are
responsible for watching over the
business profit margin and to make sure
that the infra cost is more than offset
by the business value they generate
so through these three personalized
perspectives
we see that
there are a lot of
challenges and opportunities
and as i mentioned earlier we have the
data
infra teams
looking to offload
the management on the infra complexity
we have the query users that could be a
lot more productive with the right tools
and the cron management looking to have
more visibility and control of their big
data cloud spanned
let me now share with you another career
story of mine
back then
in the world of mpp analytical databases
it is all about how to couple
storage and query
this is because
we can then minimize the disk and in
cluster network io when we process large
queries
so if someone thinks about the coupling
or separating storage on the compute
or even they're advocating for it
they will probably get laughed out of
the court
so that was that time and then
it's interesting to see and i give the
snowflake engineering team a lot of
credit in advocating for this idea and
uh and realizing that
and it's amazing to see how some
anti-mainstream idea can gradually take
over
and become the mainstream
and in contrast i think amazon redshift
probably started had a head start and
their architecture never changed never
was cloud friendly um
it's just an interesting contract to see
so my lesson here is
in order to make impact we will need to
continue to think about where the new
ideas come from and pursue them and have
the persistence in lending them
and to do that
we must not shy away from being a
contrarian
and this includes from time to time
even being a contrarian to the master
contrarians like peter thiel
so this is what i would encourage
everyone to
develop their own contrarian thinking
to conclude this talk
let me put on record
a few quote-unquote bold predictions
first of all for those of you who are
having an amazing career in data
engineering congratulations job well
done
but i'm sorry to inform you
uh you're you're dismissed
i think that
in the future
the data engineering can be moved
entirely to the cloud
so if you are a top-notch data engineer
i would suggest you talk to the data
cloud vendors
including asset blue sky
and we think you can still have an
amazing continued run for your career
if you are query users
we think you will get a lot more love
the tools you are using for sql and
other programming languages your
programming environment
will receive major upgrade
and you will have an even more
productive time
in
writing and executing your queries
and then we talk about the pricing model
something that management cio cares
about
we observed that the pricing model is
increasingly becoming more aligned to
the business value that data infra
generates but still not quite there yet
if you imagine there's a cfo query used
to close the financial book at quarterly
end
and it happens to consume the same
computer resource
as to an intern query that's exploring
some long-term idea
do you think they should really
be charged the same
so these are some open questions
regarding what the future pricing model
could look like if you're interested i
would love to talk to you offline
so as you see
we have our next 5 to 10 years of data
infra work cut out for us
and
we are not here for a quick win
i think we need to be in on a mission to
fundamentally change how data is managed
on the cloud
so towards that goal
we're starting our journey at blue sky
our technology we think will be the next
big thing
beyond cost-based optimization
we call it workload based optimization
through learning
the past users workloads
we can make their future queries faster
and cheaper
so i will repeat that part
youtube watchers might love this
through through learning the user's past
workloads
we will make the future queries faster
and cheaper
so
if you're a 10x engineer looking for
a major impact we have openings for
part-time full-time positions
and i would love to to talk to you
look forward to working together and
change the world one more time
thank you
[Applause]
you